the matrix lower the ratings Star Wars
and Kill Bill all combined sounds good
right sounds good a lot of people are
really off and on with Zack Snyder's
movies as I am myself I did who ever
really liked the owl movie it's very
difficult for me to sum up the plot of
this movie because in all honesty I just
saw the film and I'm not entirely sure
actually what the plot is that's a bad
sign
Emily Browning is sent to an institution
for the mentally insane because she
accidentally killed her sister her
father is you know doesn't want her
anymore the mother's dead he just kind
of throws her there
then all of a sudden it's not a mental
institution anymore it's a place where
young girls are thrown and then forced
to become essentially prostitutes it
just kind of switches from that at one
point and there is really no explanation
I'm being honest with you here then I
meet the other girls Abbie Cornish
Vanessa Hudgens Jena Malone Jamie Chung
from Dragonball Evolution I kind of have
a grudge against anyone involved with
that film then the main girl is then
asked to dance she's asked to show
everyone what she can do and all of a
sudden we get she's in some other world
fighting these three creatures like
jumping up into the air crushing things
blowing things up has superhuman
abilities and then all of a sudden she
opens our eyes again she's done dancing
and this little sequence that we get
with the action is never explained it
was all in your head or something didn't
meet Scott Glenn and he gives these
really weird little clues of how to get
out of this place
mental institution whorehouse whatever
it is I don't know apparently they have
to all band together to be able to
escape from this place but whenever this
girl closes her eyes
to do a dance for somebody it's an
action sequence in some crazy place that
relates to one of these five items that
she's supposed to get and I don't know
what in the world that means I have no
idea what the story is a story is so
crazy and weird and none of it makes any
sense I don't understand what's
happening what's going on okay
that's the biggest problem with this
movie a tagline of this film is you will
be unprepared that's actually very true
because on a technical level this film
is visually stunning by far the best
action sequences I have seen all year
terrific special effects really well
choreographed action yes there's a lot
of special effects done there's a lot of
fake stuff that's in there but it all is
technically amazing absolutely
mind-blowing least stunning and for that
reason I'm going to recommend this movie
I'm going to recommend this movie purely
based on the incredible action sequences
however unfortunately I don't know what
they mean it's so strange that someone
would ask her to do a dance for a
customer she closes her eyes and all of
a sudden she's fighting these things and
it has something to do with what is
actually happening in the real world
like in the real world they're going
after one of these items they need to
escape in her mind they're going after
the item but they're like fighting
Germans it looks amazing you know but
why it's like if you watch The Matrix
alright and you got those action
sequences but never at one point during
the movie does Morpheus come out and
explain everything this story just
doesn't hold you because it's so hot and
then in the end of the film how it all
kind of supposedly comes together still
doesn't really make any sense it's so
visually well-done it's essentially kind
of like Matrix Revolutions a
special-effects for that movie
magnificent however the story what in
the world is going on and I would
actually recommend revolutions purely
based on the visuals and that's all I'm
recommending about
punch a happy Cornish is excellent in
this film Emily Browning doesn't really
do anything special honestly Jimmy
chunga no not nothing special there
Vanessa Hudgens didn't do too bad the
acting for this movie overall like that
bad and Zack Snyder is a wonderful
visual director and I want to say I wish
he made it like all the other movies
that are out there I just wish he made
it a little more accessible because I
walked out with this film and I heard
people saying oh my gosh that was
horrible that was horrible it was awful
wasn't the world I had to see I heard
all these people saying these things we
want to love this type of action because
it's so fun but if we don't know what is
going on
we can't just see it for the action
sequences even though they don't make
any sense
they're very well done and I will also
say this function not even pg-13 it
should have been rated R I think three
out of four stars for sucker-punch a
very very mild recommendation if this is
down and this is up my thumb is like
right there I mean like it's it's like I
don't know visually stunning story what
the heck
you
[Music]